los países de la Unión Europea deciden
dar un paso más allá en el envío de
armamento a Ucrania los ministros de
defensa y de exteriores de la Unión
Europea han acordado el envío de un
millón de municiones al mes a Ucrania
durante todo el próximo año a lo que van
a destinar un total de 2.000 millones de
euros se trata de acelerar el envío de
armamento a Ucrania un momento crucial
de la guerra los países de la Unión
Europea se comprometen a acelerar este
envío de armamento y poder enviar lo que
necesite Ucrania tanto armamento de tipo
soviético como de tipo occidental aún
así debido a que después de un año de
guerra los países están acelerando este
envío de armamento a Ucrania los
depósitos de armamento de los países
también se están reduciendo por lo que
la Unión Europea incentiva a que los
países europeos se unan para hacer
compras conjuntas de armamento para
poder seguir enviando a Ucrania también
llenar los depósitos de los países la
estrategia es muy parecida a la que se
utilizó durante la pandemia de covid-19
con la compra conjunta de vacunas el
objetivo es aumentar el poder de
negociación reducir los precios y
también poder acelerar la producción de
armamento ahora mismo se está gastando a
una velocidad mayor a la de la
producción el jefe de la diplomacia
europea es asegura que al comentar esta
producción aumentar la economía a gran
escala a una economía de guerra para la
Unión Europea se trata de un acuerdo de
Gran calado que va a un paso Más allá de
la integración europea justo un año
después de que empezara la guerra en
ucra